Влада не вірила На жаль вона не вірила
нашим союзникам
і вона вірила росіянам
в той момент відбувалися розмови певних
чиновників з вулиці банкової з
російськими призначеними кураторами
України зокрема Дмитром козиком який
переконував що все це роблять американці
все це своїм спірують американці А я
особисто пригадую як потім американські
політики які приїздили сюди і
повідомляли зустрічалися з
представниками української влади ми
потім приїздили до нас в офіс як до
опозиції казали не може Ви хоча би нас
почуєте це реальне розв'язання ви маєте
готуватись Ви маєте рити окопи Ви маєте
озброювати людей Ви маєте мінвати Поля
ви маєте мінувати принаймні мости знаєте
мене тоді вразили Ось ті шашлики сонце
вихідні шашлик День Перемоги